I saw in West Africa from 99 John over
99 to 2002 three years during that
period cote d'ivoire where i was
resident in ibiza in fact had its first
coup d'etat I which was followed by a
succession of coup attempts unsuccessful
mostly there were some very
controversial and quite violent
elections I was also concurrently
accredited to Sierra Leone where the UN
peacekeeping force a large force 15,000
people are men was led by India which
had a sick contingent of 6,000 soldiers
I was concurrently accredited to Guinea
which has been in an uneasy equilibrium
but a very unstable equilibrium if you
like I was accredited to nature which is
another government that has not been
able to make any economic progress for
its people so yes those are the kind of
experiences I have had but at the same
time of course those are experiences
from which you learn a great deal you
you get a more mature perspective on
international relations and of course
also a different perspective on how you
look at